off the coast of Kenya in the India
Nation lie unique ecological Treasures
some in the sea and others on Islands
three of which were nearly lost to
Developers
John WAMU was in charge of the Coast
Area for Kenya's Wildlife service which
is the lawful owner of the islands I
think that's corruption or the grabbas I
think they they have their ways or bring
that which is not permissible by the
government and of course because the
government has its own mechanism see now
they were able to recover the islands
from the from the grabbas the
surrounding Waters of the casite Marine
reserve provides Sanctuary for more than
200 Dolphins it's been protected by law
since the 1970s below the surface are
endangered sea turtles and coral Gardens
that are breeding grounds for hundreds
of species of fish John says if hotels
had been built on the islands it would
have been an ecological disaster some
speculators acquired irregular titles
for them in the 1990s amid a series of
corruption scandals later the illegal
titles were bought by companies owned by
foreigners in spite of the islands
clearly being in a nature reserve some
of them sued the wildlife service
seeking to build an airstrip here they
lost the case and Drew the attention of
the authorities the investigators say
because it's completely out of sight of
the Mainland but accessible in small
boats and possibly light aircraft that
it's the perfect location for criminal
activities such as drug smuggling and
they say that one of the companies still
holds a title for this island and has
refused to hand it over
the investigators say they'll now take
the company to court the others agreed
to hand over their titles after being
investigated by Kenya's ethics and
anti-corruption commission kiss was
filed Abdi Muhammad spent decades
recovering all kinds of public property
for the government but he says it's the
first time he's ever recovered Islands
people will try to do all manner of
things and we are not saying we will
will finish or rather a completely
finished corruption in Kenya what we are
saying is let's do our bid to ensure we
reduce
whatever percentage
even if we reduce it by 10 percent good
enough
the companies you handed over the titles
won't face charges for now the islands
have at least been spared from illegal
development
Malcolm Webb Al Jazeera cassite
empanguti lower Island Kenya
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera